how's the day going good you know I
think this is where you need to go very
selfish a little setback obviously it's
unlikely that you're here without some
solid level of context of Who I am in
theories I think this is where we can
get very very very detailed so go very
very very selfish with the question
we'll see how many times we move around
if you're selling self-published books
and digital courses you're limiting the
upside of your speaking career because
you're doing sales over brand the reason
I'm one of the highest-paid speakers is
because all of you are so bought into me
because I don't sell you $1,000 thing
that you will do something like this or
you will pay 2,000 bucks to get a ticket
to a bit like so one of the things to
think about you with your business you
have options you have more like what I
had which is you have economics in the
business that are doing well I would
tell you to not monetize your audience
for as long as you possibly can because
that's gonna build more economics in the
back end but I do
well I only build brain cuz it's not
selling it I'm gonna use it now
the one caveat to that is you need
enough sales so you don't go out of
business in your ideological marathon
right but as much as you can build on
brand brand Oh a space the reason Tommy
Hilfiger and Fela are back on
fifteen-year-olds bodies is because it's
a brand
it wasn't cuz they had good sales brand
always brand that's why transformers and
spider-man an Aquaman and Wonder Woman
open movies people don't scale well is
they liked they don't even realize it
you might not even realize your
subconscious you know we talked about
subconscious bias for like female
minorities there's subconscious bias as
an operator you get the high that you're
so good at everything you actually don't
want to hire somebody to do something
that does it better than you or you love
doing it you like love knocking on the
doors so you don't want to let somebody
do that while you make a podcast but
scaling a business comes at two very
important traits one humility and two
patients also auditing your [ __ ] 24
hours so if you're sleeping 6 7 8 9
hours
what do you
doing the rest of the time and what do
you need like you might say Gary cool
I've listened to all your [ __ ] but I
need three hours a night of Netflix
that's how I decompose I'm like Mazel
Tov then like let's go back to your 8
hours that you work like what are you
doing every minute like that's where
this has gotten so the reason I can do
it like it's scary to me how lazy I
think the 29 year old me is and he was a
workaholic it's not that I try any
harder it's that I'm dramatically more
efficient it's a game of and this is for
a lot of you scaling is predicated on
your ambition versus what you're
interested in in your lifestyle at that
current moment the reason I'm great at
scaling is I don't want anything fancy
my most devastating business decisions
have been predicated at the moments when
I bought my two homes
I passed I've never said this this
clearly I passed on uber because I
bought an apartment if I just stayed in
the apartment I was in for one more year
I would have four hundred million
dollars that I don't have right now
that's about as basic as I can say it
you should be producing an ungodly
amount of LinkedIn content in whatever
form of communication comes more most
naturally to you written audio or video
I couldn't be more bullish on LinkedIn
as a content b2b place couldn't I'm
obsessed with it it's grossly
underpriced the ads are expensive ish
because they have a floor they don't do
what Google and Facebook does which
starts at the bottom they have like a
cost on the CPM but organic traction is
real like just putting your LinkedIn
profile that puts out content URL in
your email signature as somebody who
emails a lot is enough of a match to
start your Linkedin content career
like everyone's like Facebook doesn't
work anymore like no no the ad that was
working for you has been saturated and
it's costing you more and converting
less because the people that would
convert on the first thing have
converted and the feeds getting more
competitive you need to make more
content this feed is busy if it's not
contextual it's not getting consumed it
could literally be like hey are you a 42
year old woman and run it against 42
year old woman's it is crazy
you will scale from eight hundred to two
million pretty quickly if you get
Facebook and Instagram ads right and the
way you do that is little your [ __ ]
phone video after video after video now
you've made this notice how my framework
works so well for you now that you're
all in on you you [ __ ] can do it on
the FaceTime it you don't need [ __ ] you
don't need the rock you [ __ ] like hey
Atlanta I'm coming through hey Atlanta
Falcon fans I'm coming through running
against Atlanta Falcon fans with guys
buying ads for everyone is real like I
don't care what you do concrete pools
like so but the magic is in the long
tail of it imagine if you're only
talking to african-american females what
you're gonna say in that camera versus
talking to middle America 60 year olds
who care about our military it's gonna
be a completely different video people
people say things to me like in YouTube
because I have so many blogs but like
Gary why are you changing your
adjectives like they try to razz me for
pandering to my audience I'm like
they're like when you're in Atlanta in
the hood you're you're using slang like
I'm like right that's subconscious like
in the same way that when I'm talking to
a six-year-old I'm talking like
adjusting to your audience is my natural
state it's not a bad thing it's a great
thing it's why I connect with so many
different people you know so that's how
I think about content like that's what
you should be doing when Seinfeld is the
number one show on television you run
commercials you shouldn't be sitting
around predicting if Sally Magoo the
surfer is going to be around in five
years you should buy her when she's
under priced at ten
if you tell me that the three five
million people are so under priced based
on your budget and based on what you or
us thought the value of that post was or
video content well then I'd be like
let's do it to me it's a bi it's like
like do you buy one home or three homes
well if you can buy three homes for
1/100 of the value of that home if you
can buy a $400,000 home for a thousand
dollars they want to sell you that home
for a thousand dollars and you have to
buy all three of their homes that are
worth four hundred thousand but you're
paying three thousand you buy those
three homes and figure it out later
that's how I think about influencers
there's micro influencers that aren't
worth their [ __ ] $80 for the little
photo and the nurse people that are you
know the Holy Grail is creating an
influencer team that understands how to
work with seven billion people and
understand if they're a good deal or not
and make that deal that's how I think
about it that is my holy grail of
influencer marketing I can price every
person on earth and then when I speak to
them I can know if it's a good deal or
not and then I want to maximize my
$100,000 on the $100,000 best buy
because I bought 18 million dollars
worth of awareness for a hundred
thousand now that is Fantasyland but the
closest you can get to that so what does
that mean you start casting long wide
nets you have 15 interns that work for
free or minimum wage to DM everybody on
earth and ask them how much they cost
like there's a lot of things you can
then decide to do but it is not an
either/or do we bet on these three
people and they're gonna be 15 million
followers versus because it's because
you know because you're doing it it's
not about how many followers my favorite
marketing principle is the high school
party rule which is if all of you think
back to high school right now and think
about the person that was a CD popular
kid by junior year but started throwing
parties we're cool kids could go and
drink and hook up they became way more
popular on the arbitrage of their
parents weren't around that's basically
how I think you should handle this I
think you should start a podcast and
just interview the people that you
actually want to do business with and
now you've won literally the entire use
you setting an email with the title
saying I'd love to have you on our
podcast to know your journey and
thoughts of the current state a blank
are gonna get a hell of a lot more
responses then do you need to place a
front-end developer now all of a sudden
you're the first person ever to say that
Karen or Rick the technology decision
maker at a company is worthy of a 45
minute podcast they share that with
their thirteen friends on Facebook it's
also going to be the fact that you're
gonna be the first person they reach out
to when they like literally you host the
party that will work